(upbeat music)
(steam hisses)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪
Here's a quick tip from someone we love.
Hi, I'm Courtney McWilliams.
I'm the founder of MaryMac's Doggie Retreat
in New Orleans, Louisiana.
And this Gabbana.
I'm a social worker
and I specialize in overly anxious dogs.
Many facilities where you're going
to board your dog, offer daycare.
So half their daycare, at least two weeks prior
to you leaving and boarding your dog,
at least two to three times,
that way they're comfortable.
They know the staff.
It's not a stressful environment for them.
That's one of my tips.
When you're introducing your pet
to a new environment,
I would say, take them out of the home
starting 10 minutes at a time,
to different environments
to see how they will respond.
What will be good and comforting for them
is anything that reminds them of home,
like their favorite blanket,
toy, or bed, even their crate.
Because sometimes the crates are their safe spot,
that'll help reduce some anxiety.
If a thunderstorm is coming
and you want to calm your dog,
you can use a thunder jacket.
But if you don't have a thunder jacket,
you can use an old pair of tights
and use their hide to their trigger points, right?
Then they put the neck, the chest.
Chest right here and the back, the lower back.
You wanna swaddle them, like a baby
when you tie the tights.
But you want to leave the paws free
and the tail free.
Cuddling with your dog
and reading a good book,
not only helps to reduce the anxiety of the dog
but as well as the owner.
(bright music)
I love animals.
I'm Dr. Drewlittle.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪